I want to tell you about a really lovely
problem suppose you have a circle how
many ways can you draw it well there's
only one way I mean we could make it
bigger we could make it smaller we could
move it around the paper but there's
only one way so the answer for one
circle is one what if you have two
circles they could be inside each other
they could cross each other well they
could be separated so for two circles
three ways and I better tell you what
the rules are
we don't allow this kind of thing we
don't allow two circles to just kiss
they've got to make up their mind
they've got to overlap or they've got to
be separate no that's not allowed and
when we get to more circles you're not
allowed to have three going through a
point that's not allowed either and
what's more we're doing this on a piece
of paper we're doing it in technically
we're doing it in the affine plane we're
not doing it on the projective plane if
we were doing projective geometry we
could take a circle and move the center
out to infinity and it would become a
straight line that's not allowed
all you can do is move the circles
around the radii don't matter you can
make in big circles little circles I
mean obviously this is the same as that
or this you can move them around as long
as they don't cross in mirror images
count the same they're the same as the
original picture we know what the answer
is for two circles there are three what
about three circles the answer is 14 and
here they are so first of all obviously
we could do three in a row three circles
separate from each other or we could do
three that are linked or we could do a
nested pair and a separate one in fact
we could take any of the three that we
had for two circles and wrap a circle
around them so we could do that one and
put a circle around it so we'd get that
or I could take this one and put a
circle around it and we'd get that or I
could take this one and put a circle
around it and we'd get that and then we
could put
circle next to so now we have 7 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 we're halfway there
this one here can be modified a bit a
Meads be meet see see could mean a and
we would get something that looks like
this and we get a Venn diagram a B and C
and they intersect in all possible ways
but there's another way that could
happen we could have don't forget that
doesn't matter how big or small the
circles are I've drawn it maybe I should
have made the overlap bigger this is
almost the same as the Venn diagram
except there's no point where all three
meet so we're up to nine and we need
five more and I'll take another bit of
paper I'll start off by drawing two that
overlap and then I could put a third one
there in inside one but not inside the
other
I could put a third one there so it
crosses the line where this is inside
that or I could put it inside the
overlap or I could put it so the
intersection looks like that and then
there's one more its subtly different
from that one looks like that and you
can see here we had these two
overlapping this one the third circle
was inside the points where they met
here it enclosed them so these two is
strictly different of course you might
think that I'm now gonna go and put the
circle here for example but that's the
same as this so there are just five more
and the total is 14 that's pretty easy
but not trivial to do easy to miss one
if you start doing it the question is
what happens next Jonathon Wilde
professor of music at McGill University
he has continued the sequence out to
five terms and for four there are a
hundred and seventy-three ways to do it
and even for three yeah the
rearrangements are quite pretty but when
Jonathan Wilde classified the four
circles and five circles the pictures
some of them are really amazing
they're just brilliant I mean this is
mathematics this is geometry but the
results
and I'd like to show you this is the
complete set of arrangements of four
circles you can see you start off with
four disjoint circles and then they can
be nested in various obvious ways but
when you get to more complicated
configurations some of the arrangements
are really delicate remember you can
make the circles as big or as small as
you like look at that one and going down
look at these this is a very delicate
configuration so we don't know we know
the answer for five even more
complicated and we know nothing more
we don't have an upper bound for the
number we don't ever know about I think
it would be great to hang to draw the
pictures to all 17,000 of the first five
things and hang them along the Great
Wall of China it's more than long enough
you know what is it thirteen thousand
miles or something so we'd have plenty
of space but it would look awesome
now this seems like it should be easier
it seems like there's something there
should be just some equation for you
know when when the Sunburst circles is
end you have you have this equation but
it's not that you know it's not that
simple no I mean one thing you can do is
look at the pattern of intersections say
we have three circles a B and C you
could ask does a meet B does a meet C
does a me be beat see you can write down
what's called a truth table it's
described by a boolean function which
says which circles intersect the trouble
is if you specify the intersections that
doesn't tell you how to draw them and it
doesn't tell you how many ways
throughout and draw them it's really
tricky there may be no ways Jonathon
Wilde found the some arrangements of
five circles that should exist but don't
conceivably you could do the following
you could have four circles which were
linked in sequence in a chain we've got
a b c and d four circles a meets BB meet
CC meets d d meets a and the fifth
circle would be like this you can draw
it as an ellipse but you can't draw it
as a circle that's e so the intersection
Hatton's the ABCD IRA told you about e
meets a and B and C and D and it
contains the intersection of a and D and
it contains the intersection of B and C
it does not contain the intersection of
C and D and a and B you cannot draw that
Jonathon Wilde and his co-author showed
that this could not be realized with
circles it can't be realized with
ellipses so as I said even if you
specify the way these circles meet each
other what you might call the boolean
the truth table showing the intersection
pattern and of course as you know if you
have in this case five circles you draw
a column and you mark it a B C D and E
and then here you put a 0 or a 1
depending on whether they meet or not so
for instance here a meets be true so 1 1
naught naught naught would get a 1 so
for each of the possible and here we've
got 32 all binary intersection so it's a
function of five boolean variables
whether they meet with that particular
configuration or not so then it's
described by a binary vector of length
32 and so the number of them is 2 to the
32 and for each of them
well maybe you can draw it maybe not and
maybe you can draw it in more than one
way we don't know I always like having a
look at the daily challenges here on
brilliant and as we scroll down there's
one that caught my eye for obvious
reasons because it circles circles and
triangles and hexagons oh my let's have
a look at this one now let many of the
daily challenges it starts off with
something pretty simple we've got an
equilateral triangle and a regular
hexagon there and it says those dark
blue shaded regions are similar so how
does the area of the shaded region in
that hexagon compare to the one in the
Triangle what do you think is that
one-and-a-half times bigger two times
bigger three times bigger maybe even
four times bigger this is just an
example of some of the content you're
gonna find on brilliant besides the
daily Channel
there's quizzes and courses and puzzles
all sorts of great stuff a lot of it's
free you can go and have a look straight
away or you can sign on for a premium
membership that gives you access to
everything and if you go to brilliant
org slash numberphile they'll know you
came from here and you'll get 10% off a
premium membership not a bad deal that
brilliant org
don't forget the slash numberphile and
now thanks to them for supporting this
episode it's a simple problem beautiful
pictures wide open
[Music]